so uh we basically
um
we listened to customers we did
iterations on the product
improved it and eventually got some like
the first uh paying customers and then
we raised our
state funding and series a and
eventually acquired by intel
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by home adventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i have with us today johai etun
the ceo of converge io which he
co-founded to provide data scientists
and developers with an end-to-end
platform to build and deploy machine
learning models
converge io was acquired by intel in
2020 as part of its strategy to get into
ai software and prior to converge io
yokai was a data scientist providing
machine learning consulting services and
ex-idf intelligence a forbes 30 under 30
and a coder since the age of seven
you hi etune welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you for joining me all the
way from jerusalem how are you
good good thank you thank you for having
me
i'm i'm so excited to have you are you
ready to talk about ai with me i know
that you don't talk about it at all on
your day today so i'm excited to give
you room to talk about it
yeah i'm happy to talk about ai
amazing
yo hi where where did your passion for
ai come from you've been running
converge for the last
few years an amazing company
and
you know one of the biggest prides in
israel and
and you're you're doing some amazing
things helping companies build and scale
their ai operations but but where is
your personal passion for
for data science coming from
yeah
so um i think it all goes back like to
me as a
as a kid basically i started developing
stuff
building software since i was like the
age of seven built some websites and
uh
also built some stuff for other uh
customers when i was young
and as um
after i finished in the army i was in
the intelligence and i joined the hebrew
university
i was exposed to the
to the world of machine learning of ai
and as a developer that likes to build
stuff
that was extremely
fascinating for me it was like the new
type of software software 2.0
and i fell in love with ai and i started
building stuff and uh
and doing some contracting work like
consulting work in ai and machine
learning for other companies and it just
uh expanded from there
now as you're
uncovering this new world software 2.0
and you're you're figuring out you know
your place with it you've done some
incredible things here you've also
you're the cto of webbing live as and
the founder of the of the hebrew
universities in the innovation lab and
the ceo of accessible and you're working
with a group of scientists to build
you know with artificial intelligence
before starting converge so
what what was the trigger for actually
starting a company in this domain
because obviously by the time that
you're starting converge in 2016 pretty
much every you know it's known that data
scientists are a scarce resource in the
world
and you know so many opportunities are
present
right
yeah so that's a good question so i
started doing
uh software as a consultancy like
specifically around machine learning
we built some cool stuff around speech
recognition and natural language
processing and stuff like that like
under get extracting insights from
conversations and stuff like that
and uh i did those projects with leia
and she is my co-founder and uh and cto
at uh converge
and as we built models built ai we saw
that that were sort of like facing some
challenges that are not
uh that didn't really happen with
general software development
ai is similar but it's different and uh
we basically built converge
as an internal product something that we
used ourselves to build our stuff
and uh it was very helpful for us we
started can help many other data science
teams as well
so
we decided uh
to build a company and basically took
that step from you know doing a
consultancy business to like building uh
a startup with vc funding and all those
kind of stuff
how easy was it
not not to run the company that's
obviously hard but to to have that
conviction
that you're onto something here that you
know many people need that the problem
that you're facing is one that it
resonates with many others and that this
is something that can actually become
big big enough to get you know good vc
funding from
yeah
so it wasn't easy um i mean we did we as
a developer we always like to build
stuff um and both leia and myself
had this passion
of building stuff building stuff that
people use
and building tools for developers it's
like i think it's like the best uh
thing to do like
best product to build
but
the product that was helpful for us like
it was valuable for us that we we
basically talked to many other data
scientists to see if this could be
useful for them
and once we got like a lot of yes
uh which obviously we we got a lot of
no's in the beginning but we basically
iterated the product a few times
and uh and then it was like it was a
no-brainer because both of us really
like we really liked the startup world
and we wanted to build a business and a
company
and we just felt that we got to some
sort of like a mini product market fit
so we just
took the
the train
with me though those early days as you
as you're working together and and
you're building something so special
you know six years later obviously
you're at right now with dozens of
employees amazing funding offices around
the world
what was it like back then running this
new startup
wow yeah well it was it was a wild
journey like when we started
it was just basically
myself we were coding like i don't know
16 hours a day for actually
yeah until we have like the first
version
and uh
as as a developer ceo um once after you
build stuff you need to get people to
to use it
and uh i'm like you know like all of the
other developers i'm i'm shy i'm an
introvert
uh again doing demo sales demos and
pitches to to other to potential
customers was very hard for me
uh but but eventually we managed to
evolve and we we built a really good
product that was very appealing to other
data scientists
so uh we basically um
we listened to customers we did
iterations on the product
improved it and eventually got some like
the first uh paying customers and then
we raised our
state funding and series a and and
eventually acquired by uh intel
incredible and and so as you're going
through this journey you're mentioning
that you're an introvert and that you
have uh you know you're then you're your
developer
does that conflict with you also being
the ceo
is that is that a
challenge
yeah yeah so it was a challenge but
eventually i think
one of the good things that i managed uh
to do is to to evolve with the startup
uh journey so
at the beginning like the first uh few
months we it was just even like the
first year we was all about coding like
really 16 hours a day
coding debugging fixing bugs and all
those kind of stuff
then
learning how to sell a product
so
that was hard but thankfully i it was
it was selling to other friends like
other data scientists we always say that
converge is a platform that was built
by data scientists for data scientists
so
uh it was easy for me to communicate
those values of converge to other
fellow data scientists
and then we we need to have to do like
another evolution of converge the
company selling to investors and that's
a it's a different pitch
it's similar but it's different
and now it's all about you know building
a business building sales building
marketing
scaling converge within intel working
with intel as a corporation
many many new challenges and i think
the the secret
or
like
the thing that helps me
uh to scale converge and to get to new
like accomplishments and success
is to know that my job as a ceo is
evolving
every quarter like every quarter it's
something new it's new skills i need to
develop
and it's fun and i like it i love it
actually
so
going back to
april
and and you're and you're looking at it
sorry november i believe in 2020.
and you know you're in talks with intel
and with leia and your investors you
have hanako you have jvp so it's amazing
amazing partners
what are the considerations on your end
not you know it's you know i get i'm
lucky that i get to speak to somebody
here who who sold the company to to
intel and obviously it's a great
partnership and you're continuing to
operate with converge and and continue
to build out the product within but
what what are the what are the thoughts
going on on your head and the
consideration because
you know in there are people that may
say
wait why sell now maybe maybe continue
building a larger company and working
within intel is different than running
an independent startup
yeah
yeah it's it's a good question and we
had this uh discussions you know back
in october uh
like last year
and
i think what eventually was uh
helped us to make this decision is that
one it was a good offer
like for everyone for our investors for
us for the employees it was a good
it was it was a good offer and a good
outcome
second
we wanted to build something that is
really big in ai
like
be like huge we wanted to make an impact
in the ai world
and to do so we felt that partnering
with intel
uh a company that is looking to invest
more in ai and have huge vision around
ai
uh all over the world
that was like a perfect match for us
and we even see it like a a year passed
and we already released like
some new uh uh like features like
converge meta cloud was announced we're
going to have a big announcement also
uh in the next few months so we're
continuing we're continuing to evolve
and develop even as we are now
part of intel and intel actually one of
the things that
we were we are doing as part of the
acquisition is that they kept converge
brand
uh right and this right this is great
because they understand that they want
to get to developers
to get to developers that's like the
best way to do it to have a you know a
brand of buy developers for developers
and stuff like that i love it and you
know what i really want to articulate
here and touch on is what you said about
the motivation and and the way that
you're you're talking how when you're
thinking through the acquisition you're
you're saying yeah you know it's a good
financial outcome for everybody that's
great but
what's really matters here is the fact
that you know we went on this mission to
build a company that can help help
companies scale ai and help push ai
forward in the world and we believe that
we can do it better with the backing of
intel within intel as a as an ai
powerhouse in the world and and i think
that that's just really awesome because
i think that just shows also to the
inner motivations of why you started out
on this journey
and and obviously there's a great
financial outcome but but even more than
that it's
being in a place where you really are
making the biggest impact that you can
make right
yeah exactly like
ai is evolving very very fast there are
so many companies that are now looking
to leverage ai
and all of the ai development is being
done on ai compute and intel you know
is very strong with processors and and
hardware
and they they're looking to invest more
more in getting to ai and
much more than we could do as a startup
we can do now with uh with intel
right
share with me a little bit about
the way that you see the scaling ai
operations today and how converge
specifically is
positioned within this world
yeah so
so uh yeah so
basically machine learning today
is the demand for building
ai based solutions whether it's
autonomous driving or speech recognition
or
nlp chat bots analytics models all those
kind of stuff it's it's increasing
uh dramatically like the demand is
it's crazy and uh today to build ai
it's uh basically
it's a there's many many challenges you
need to build ai you need to focus on to
invest time in infrastructure in
resource management in model management
uh tracking models monitoring models
uh scaling the the hardware and all
those kind of stuff a lot of stuff and
very little left for the actual magic
like the actual data science stuff
and this is why we do exactly at
converge we basically automate a lot of
the grunt work of data science
development
and help the data scientist basically to
build more
with
with less time now besides the
automation part that we do
there is a very interesting thing that's
happening today in the world with
machine learning so machine learning
is going through now what software
development
went through like 20 30 years ago
companies are looking to figure out how
they can standardize the process of
machine learning development just as
they standardize software development
you know like ci cd stuff and and github
and all those kind of stuff
same exact things are now going through
uh with uh with machine learning
and converge we built basically to help
organization to standardize the process
of model development and deployment
so if you're looking at
perhaps an example of a way that you're
interacting with the website with with a
company with the where there's with
their machine learning operations you
you're trusted by some some incredible
companies from intel to light tracks to
to the likes
what how does it actually impact the
company in practical terms
yeah
so um companies can now scale machine
learning when they're using converge
they can actually scale to
hundreds of data scientists building
thousands of models and
and basically getting much more
from their data science teams for
example we have a company a few
customers that are basically training
thousands of models every day
which is crazy like
without converge it would probably be
impossible
or it will take him take them like few
years of engineering
so those are the kind of things that is
very nice to see
also we have some very unique use cases
of complex infrastructure and hardware
for ais for example one of our customers
seagate
the disc
hard drive manufacturing company
so they use converge on uh on a hybrid
cloud ai deployment where they
basically do defect detection in all of
their manufacturing facilities so a hard
drive drop is going through the
manufacturing process
there is a there it there is a system
that basically take pictures of the disk
and if there is some defects then it
automatically goes back through the
manufacturing process or they put it
aside and those are the kind of models
that we really like to see because
they're actually solving some really
big business problems um and with
converge they can actually operate uh
and basically manage those models
is it trivial for the companies that
you're approaching that this is
something that they need do they realize
already that this is a and this is a
pain point of theirs and and it's a
pretty you know smooth sailing from
there
wow so that's a good question because
when we started
it was
we basically had to educate the market
we were basically pitching converge and
companies were like
okay
not sure if we're facing those issues
now we probably will face them in a few
years so let's talk uh in the future and
we came really early to the market
and it actually was a good it was a good
thing also because we managed to get
all those early adopters
and uh in the past year because of the
high demand for ai solutions so more and
more companies are are
understanding the pain
uh and the value proposition of converts
so
um in the past year yeah our sales team
it was it was easier for them than uh
it was for leia and myself like three
four years ago
uh but uh yeah there are still companies
that are not
there yet but the the growth is very
nice to see
hey yo i have the the most important
question that we touched on this theme a
little bit until now but i just want to
really make sure that i'm that i'm
getting the right answer here
why why do you do what you do why
today do you wake up put on the converge
sweatshirt and do what you do
yeah so um
so i think there are a few answers first
of all i really love the people
in the company
and
everyone my
co-founder management any any employee
in the company i really i enjoy working
with them
great partners uh for the journey
and uh
and still as a as a developer even just
i was as was a kid when i was seven
years old
i really enjoy building stuff building
software building products building
companies
building
sales building marketing i
i love it creating stuff
is uh is something that i really like
and thankfully also today with intel
uh we get to continue to innovate and
grow and build uh so this is really what
uh is exciting for me
thank you very much for the time for the
energy for the for the awesome work that
you're doing to help companies scale ai
for the authenticity and for the mission
driven mindset that you're in i love it
and i'm inspired by it thank you very
much and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you very much